brad pitt's ongoing custody battle with
angelina jolie continues the 57-year-old
actor's petition to challenge a decision
made in the case has been denied that's
life isn't it brad's request which he
filed in september came after judge john
outerkirk was disqualified from the
custody case that action vacated all the
judge's decisions including a previous
ruling that granted the actor more time
with his and angelina's five minor
children pax zahara shiloh and twins
vivian and knox it's a topic family law
specialist kelly chang rickard spoke to
e.t about in july so you know the whole
crux of this appeal is that they felt
judge udekirk was biased and therefore
should have disqualified himself that
was their entire argument you know i
think the other side is saying well she
agreed to him initially when she was
represented by a different lawyer and so
lots of arguments were being presented i
believe there were two or three matters
that ludacris was on he had disclosed
many many many cases and i guess there
were three and they were insignificant
cases that's what brad pitt's team were
arguing and after all that arguing comes
the latest ruling e.t can confirm that
the california supreme court denied
brad's request to review the california
appellate court's ruling to disqualify
the private judge e.t has reached out to
his reps for comment meanwhile angelina
is looking forward to the future in a
statement shared to et the maleficent
star's attorney robert olson stated that
the actress quote welcomes the decision
and is quote glad for the family to now
move forward cooperatively the only
thing i can say is in very very bitter
nasty custody cases such as this one
it's not unusual for the parties to keep
fighting until the kids are grown
because when the kids are grown they're
outside the jurisdiction of the courts
but right now they're fighting because
the courts can still rule on the kids
but once they're 18 you know they're on
your own they're adults so unfortunately
you see this a lot in bitter cases is
that they'll keep fighting until the
children are legally adults
that's what's happening here while
things may be rocky between brad and
angelina the kids are enjoying moments
in the spotlight the actress's family
has been by her side at premieres for
her new movie eternals across the globe
even rocking vintage looks worn by their
mom in the past and while speaking with
e.t at the uk premiere for the marvel
movie angelina shared what it's been
like having them join her on the carpet
i think the important thing is they
they've been
they haven't made a choice they've been
public sin for their whole lives and so
to try to find a way where they can
uh
not be kind of overwhelmed by it but
just be be in it in a comfortable way
and it's a tiny piece of our life we are
just a family but this little piece of
our life where this is a moment i'm
happy that they're able to to have some
fun with it and not take it too
seriously and
and start to explore themselves even
with their fashion